[Music]
let's go to connor in scottsdale az
what's up brother how are we doing
what's going on dr d pleasure to talk
with you man it's a pleasure to talk to
you brother how's it going
dude it's going really well first let me
start off with uh been a been a listener
since uh before day one remember the uh
the ramsey episode when he introduced
you as a personality and then how
excited it was to you starting a show so
big fan man
thanks brother you are in rare air
there's only like
there's not a lot of you guys so thank
you so much appreciate it
no problem
uh so want to get your thoughts and i'll
let you dig into it on burnout
um you know is is burnout a real thing
uh what are some of the i guess side
effects of it is it physical mental and
how do you know if you're experiencing
true burnout man so yes
thousand percent it's real it's a
biochemical issue
uh i think sometimes it gets lumped into
a character issue or you're not tough
enough issue or things like that
um but yes you can your body can get
cooked
the best book i've ever ever ever read
seen heard about on this topic is by the
nygotsky sisters and i'll link to it in
the show notes it's called burnout
that's the name of the book and they
wrote it for women i've talked to
numerous men who find it incredibly um
important as well and are valuable i
find it valuable as well
but using their framework which i love
you can break down exhaust uh you can
break down burnout into a couple of
different things number one well let me
back out you're experiencing this is
that why you're asking
no full on yeah okay okay so i'm gonna
break this framework down but i wanna
use you as the as the
case study okay
number one is this deep sense of
complete and utter exhaustion you open
your eyes in the morning and you're
tired
and somewhere about 7 30 8 30 a.m you
start thinking about
dude in 10 more hours i can be right
back here
yeah exactly
so walk me through it yeah exactly
um
i mean just to give you a very quick
backstory um
you know my my entire life i've always
felt with
that deep sense of like not feeling good
enough and not you know always needing
to prove myself which led into you know
being in competitive motorsports and
and kind of being put in that world of
um
i've heard you say it a couple times
that rough tough talk hard charger of
prove myself be stronger kill or be
killed kind of
mentality and over the last five years
you know i've experienced a few
um i guess some would say a
life big life events you know
with my
becoming a new dad and then my
uh
my ex
trying to take her life and then
changing jobs and changing careers and
being a single parent and
meeting
meeting my now
absolutely beyond epic wife
and then going through the crazy
immigration process
get you know she's from a different
country and and kind of when you add all
this stuff on top of it along with this
you know
um
challenging
environment that we're in now with the
with culture
and and kind of just society of being
that all right
you know i'm the i'm the man of the
house and my wife's russian so she's
very uh
you got to be a real man
and
what i'm noticing is
the way i
personally the way i personally
react to stress is
be stronger work harder be better
and
the more stress it's put on me the
harder
i want to work and the harder i want to
you know provide and the harder i want
to push myself
to the point where
i'm super blessed with with a boss
that's you know hey work as many hours
as you want which is a blessing and a
curse because
i look at it and go you know yeah we're
we're we're walking through the baby
steps and
you know we're we're in baby step 3b and
so i'm like
you know
gazelle intensity and so i'm you know i
turn around and and my mindset is be the
gazelle but then
you've used the metaphor a couple times
that the gazelle gets tired yeah and
my mindset is how do you turn around as
a gazelle and grab the lion you know by
the throat and be like how do you be
better and
it's kind of it just all led up to
when i contacted you i've talked to
different you know pastors and
counselors
and everything and listening to your
show like man i would love to get
you know your
your tips and tricks and
your insight in it because a few weeks
ago i think the last
i'd say the last five years kind of all
just hit like i wasn't sick
but just just moving and getting out of
bed just it just wasn't happening yeah
it just so here's what so burnout
is when your body says
dude i'm out
at some point your body says
we've
this is as much as i got right now
and we can
make it it you might get the flu you
might get sick you might get cancer you
might do any number of things
but at some point the alarms have been
ringing for long enough that your body
finally says it's like dude it's like
it's like uh
driving your car and never changing the
oil
and then someone's saying dude you got
to pull over and change the oil and
you're like no bro you've got to drive
faster drive faster
like okay dude but like the light's
blinking on the dash
and you just say drive faster at some
point your car engine just melts
together
if you don't do maintenance on the car
just quit running
and so yeah burnout you you just you
mean you just walked through
the entire
bricks in the backpack
like you were born into a story
into a culture that said you're not a
human being you're a human doing
you are what you accomplish so
accomplish well and you found some
accomplishment you found some esteem
which is awesome which is great in
motorsports which revs your body up
all day every day
and
you almost die every day proving
yourself literally
and then you move on to all those
different traumas and so yeah dude
there's just a point when your body just
goes brother i'm i if you're not gonna
stop i'm gonna stop us
and then it all comes crashing down by
the way you gotta now you've got a new
culture that you are
um
connecting with that has a picture of
what masculinity looks like and what
strength looks like and all that
so
it sounds like you're tired man
of all of it so let me
um
yes yes and no
um
how
so with you know without going into
obviously we could we could
i would love to and we could talk for
hours and hours and hours
how
when your body says you know chemically
enough enough the engine oil is gone the
engine's you know dead
you've pushed so hard that you know and
i can get all of that you know i get
pacing yourself in a long distance race
and taking care of the vehicle and
everything like that but how do you
fight the
when the engine stops when you burn out
the feelings of
you're not good enough be stronger you
shouldn't burn out you're a failure
because you're
sleeping in bed all day long you know
there's male figures in my life that the
joke was
growing up and that's all i ever saw was
you know i only worked a half day at my
job what do we do with the other 12
hours is up to us yeah
no and so it's and that's that's that's
a voice of someone who's cooked
so my hope for everybody is you never
fully get there
because it's hard to come back
it's hard how do you come back
you got to be really intentional and
often people come back in rehab or they
come back in divorce court or they come
back and their children are filing for
emancipation
usually or they're just got fired and
they got to figure out a new career
coming back can be hard it happens every
single day that's why i do the show
everybody everybody can come back
i believe that all my my soul i wouldn't
be doing this
um but it's hard
so i want you to take take the engine
metaphor away and i want to give you
another metaphor that i think is going
to be better
so imagine you know anything about
plumbing at all
absolutely okay so
um
you've got like a clog
you can run in your pipes and you know
your sink starts backing up you can run
to the hardware store and grab a bottle
of drano dump it in there and chances
are it will it will at least let that
thing drain
and it's bad for your pipes it's bad for
everything but it's bad for the sewer
system it's bad for everything but it
will clear clear that that that clog
if every morning you woke up and just
dump drano into your into your sink
every day
in short order it would eat through the
pipes
it would destroy everything
and so i want you to think about that
when it comes to your body's stress
response
our stress response is still ancient
technology it is running on
um
hey there's a tiger and it's gonna try
to eat us and i gotta get away or i
gotta kill it or it's gonna kill me
and
whenever you walk through a life
thinking i'm not good enough i just
screwed that up i should have done this
that's gotta be better i gotta get done
faster i gotta work more i gotta do more
all the time your body just has a few
responses to that and it is a cortisol
and adrenaline and stress hormones over
and over and over and over
and that's like dumping drano and then
to solve that problem you hop on a
motorbike and drive 95 miles an hour and
try not to die
and it's like well we're back in it
again and then you are in a marriage
that is falling apart and you're back in
it again
and a home becomes a place that's not
safe
so you leave a bear cave and go home and
there's a tiger on your couch
and then and then and then and then
and then you see your aunts and uncles
or your dad or your grandad
who just most of your memories are them
sitting on the couch
because their bodies say screw you man
or they're
they're seven tall boys into every
single day of their life
because beer turns the alarms down a
little bit it works for a while until it
kills you
or you just get cooked
and then meth and coke and all and 17
red bulls it will speed you up to get
through a day and you collapse and do it
again the next day and do it again the
next day
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to back up and stop putting drano in
the sink
and so
i want you to think of burnout as this
is from the negotsky sisters i love it
it is the result of unfinished business
you haven't completed the stress cycle
you spun up some stress in your life and
you haven't completed it
you got to let that thing cycle through
which is why
a break isn't um
a reward a break is an essential part of
a hard day
relationships being with people going
for walks exercise eating right sleeping
those are not
things that you add on to your life
those are core principles that you have
to have
you have to have days of the week that
you take off
if you are going to be gazelle intense
it's got to be short order you got to
crush it crush it crush it with a i can
do this for three years and that is it
and then i've got to stop putting drano
in that drain for a season
and
you have to deal with those bricks in
your backpack brother those stories you
carrying around with you
and here's how i do it i'll tell you
exactly how i do it because i've got
those same ones in my bag
okay
i have a small little black
um journal and then what i'm about to
tell you sounds cheesy and stupid don't
let your buddies see it but actually i
don't care because we need to change the
picture of what masculinity even looks
like
um
and it's a story's journal that i carry
with me
and i'll write it down and now i've been
doing it so long now that it's i don't
have to write it down all the time
because now i can spin it out pretty
quick out of my head but that
you should have i write that down
i can't believe you didn't i write that
down
you just need to suck it up and man up i
write that down
and i look at it i literally will extend
my arm i talked about this in a recent
show i will extend my arm at arm's
length and i will look at it jocko calls
that detachment
michael singer calls that mindfulness
you can call it whatever you want
whether you're a navy seal or you're a
um like a guru i don't care
you got to get some space from that
thought and then demand evidence is that
true
and that's the magic brother right there
am i the worst dad the answer is no
am i a crappy man
no does manning up mean
um that i don't get to sleep no
that's foolish it's nonsense look around
brother all men are dying young
diseases of despair they're all addicts
and
it's crazy when you look across the the
culture
right it's insane yeah absolutely we
need a generation of men to take care of
themselves now hear me say not work real
you got to still work your butt off be
really really
um uh
set high goals man
be really ambitious
and no not a problem here okay but look
set those high goals be ambitious and
know that ambition is not gonna save you
it's not gonna make everything better
there is no dollar amount that's gonna
make you go now
i'm worthy that doesn't exist
it's both and
be ambitious have high goals
and know
what's gonna
make your heart still
is a great marriage
is kids that love being around their dad
those moments when you're just fishing
and everything's quiet and you're not
catching anything and you think
this is right
those are the things that heal you
not more money and more accomplishments
and more titles and more straps on the
wall
and so it's both and and you we live in
a culture that tells you either or and
this is why i think most people are
exhausted
like you just need to sit at home and
the government will mail you checks
that's ridiculous we have purpose we are
have we are designed to contribute
as my friend ken coleman says you gotta
have a purpose you gotta get we're
designed to work
and
that work in and of itself won't
heal you it's both and
and so what does that mean you've got to
re-examine your meaning why are you
doing what you're doing
do you have that
do i absolutely why are you getting up
every day conor
i want to provide a better you know life
for no that's external not only that's
external what about you
what do you want
i i don't have that it's it's every
every reason i have is external okay
there's zero internal reasons because
then it gets into a whole nother topic
of i feel selfish if i have too many
internal reasons that's and that's hey
so that's a story you write down i'm
selfish for taking care of me bullcrap
i'm selfish for changing the oil in my
car what
i'm selfish for uh putting wiper fluid
in in my car what
that doesn't even make sense
and i'm not getting onto you i'm getting
onto our culture here
and so that's a story you write down and
you hold it out and go no that's
nonsense i have to take care of conor
otherwise conor can't take care of
anybody else
but so many men their identity is what
they provide for other people
and i need men to start looking in the
mirror and saying what do i need
how can i contribute to my well-being so
that i can then do these other things
that the world needs us so desperately
to be doing
so you've got to re-examine meaning
you've got to move your body and
discharge this energy
okay
you have to have a regular practice of
exercise of moving your body up doing
something going for walks
and if you have a high high stress job
if you're still running motocross you're
still doing high stuff then i want you
to lift weights and go for walks
not dump a marathon on top of all that
stuff because there's a point when that
stress just becomes toxic it just eats
your it just eats your body inside out
okay and then the third one is human
connection
sleep you gotta have good relationships
and i recommend i know you love your
wife's a saint an angel you gotta have
male buddies do you have that
um none my age all
significantly older than me just because
i love mentors so i no i don't really
have any friends my exact age so what
i've learned from myself
is that we often have older male mentors
because it gives us a reason to have a
relationship
we can say we're learning something
and because we don't think we're worthy
of just having a regular relationship
and so your goal is your your new
challenge is to get male friends your
age and do stuff
go fishing fix bikes mow each other's
yards
just grab a beer and laugh and play
poker i don't care what it is
and if at all possible bring your kid
along too so that he has a picture in
his head of what friendship looks like
because you don't have that
you have a picture of men going home and
just sitting on the couch and staring
off into space
and then the final thing was i want you
to start
being creative do you have a hobby at
all brother
oh yeah okay i want you to continue
that's that's tough because my hobby is
my job so it's ah okay then you gotta
get something else you gotta get
something else it's hard
because i know a lot of mechanics
they're mechanics and they go home and
they spend the next four hours working
on their car you know what i say
i would love to see you do something
else
to get creative and expand your mind but
i also don't want to take away your art
and i get that so i don't know what you
do for a living but i get that and get
messy
if you are a cop and then you go home
and try to solve crimes at night you're
gonna you're gonna melt your brain
if you're a plumber and then for
at night time your your
your hobby is more plumbing you're gonna
you can just make yourself bonkers
absolutely so
you gotta have a hobby where you can be
creative and creativity can be cooking
it can be
re go take dancing classes go take learn
guitar i don't care dude be a poet i
don't care what it is go hunting but you
got to find some create creative outlets
and then i want you to start a gratitude
journal
every day of your life
i want you to wake up and write down
five things you're grateful for i got my
gratitude journal in my bag too i carry
two journals with me i do
every day of my life i'm grateful for
this and over
a month two months six months a year
you're gonna change your body chemistry
through gratitude and there's a billion
studies for that
um check out that book um burnout
i want to redefine what it looks like to
be a man
we're going to create a third path
i do need you to lift weights i need you
to be strong i need you to be there for
your community and
i need you to have relationships and
friends and hobbies i need you to look
in the mirror and say i can't help
others be well if i'm not well
you got to start with you you got to put
your oxygen mask on first
and if you sleep and take care of your
body then you can show up when the world
needs strong arms
if you are creative and well then you
can help solve some of these vexing
challenges that are that we're all
wrestling with
don't sit at home and collect checks and
don't step into a swim gym it's both
you got to go work and you got to find
meaning you got to find purpose and you
got to rest and change oil
you got gotta stop dumping drano down
the sink